Speaker 1: Let's try instead.
Manuel from Florida, welcome.
Speaker 3: Hey.
Nice to speak with you.
Speaker 1: Likewise.
Speaker 3: Florida is doing doing just fine.
Is that right?
Pretty darn.
Yeah.
It feels like I'm walking out into an now
that whenever I leave my house, though, I
hide that.
Speaker 1: Well, at least the house isn't
so hot.
Speaker 3: Yeah.
No, that's true.
The bills are pretty high because of that.
But I bet I mean, we have to take it.
Speaker 1: I'm curious, what's like your what's
your, like, top electrical bill in the summer?
Speaker 3: So I have this like 1500 square
foot house and in the summer, it could get
to $250.
Speaker 1: Oh, I have to tell you, that's
not that bad.
And you keep you're running the AC almost
24 seven, I assume.
Speaker 3: Oh, yeah.
Speaker 1: Okay.
That's actually not that shocking.
That's.
That's all right.
Well, fair.
I thought you were going to tell me $800 or
something.
Speaker 3: Oh, wow.
I didn't know electricity was that expensive
in other places.
Speaker 1: I think there are places where
if you run the AC all every day, you can get
some crazy bills.
Yeah, but good.
You're not.
That's a problem you're not dealing with,
at least.
Speaker 3: Yes.
Yeah.
Yes.
But yeah, I did wanted to ask you this question.
So I was speaking with somebody about, you
know, this contentious topic of abortion rights
and whatnot.
Yes.
And, you know, the topic tends to revolve
around when life begins and stuff.
And I've heard people say that it's science
can tell us when it begins.
I've heard people say science can't even tell
us when it ends.
And I just get kind of concerned.
And I wonder, is it practical for us to.
To make such definitions?
Or should we look at life and death like in
a nuanced way and.
Like.
Yeah.
Speaker 1: Well, I don't actually think I
don't think the solution is everybody agrees
to look at when life begins in a nuanced way.
I think what the issue is that even if we
got some answer as to when life begins, it
still isn't going to change anyone's mind
if they're against abortion for religious
reasons.
If imagine that science said, hey, you know
what?
And by the way, the real issue is when are
we talking about a person?
Not when life begins.
I mean, no one would deny that a clump of
cells is a form of life.
The relevant question is, are we talking about
a person?
And if it's a person, does it get due process?
Does it get citizenship?
Does it get child support?
Can you get the child tax credit when you're
pregnant?
You know, all these other things that are
really about personhood rather than life.
But imagine that science said, hey, life begins
at nine weeks and six days into the gestational
period.
Do we then all agree about abortion?
I mean, it just in that sense, it's a red
herring, you know what I mean?
Speaker 3: Yeah, 100%.
And whenever I do talk about this, I do like
to frame it in the the personhood kind of
way.
Right.
Because I mean, science is ever changing and
and who knows, right?
Like, we may understand that a nine week old
fetus has a full conscious right.
But at the end of the day, we assign personhood.
And we value.
Like the choice of the woman in her life and
her safety in these ways.
Right.
Regardless of of that.
But yeah, personhood is great.
But I just get I get worried because it kind
of makes pro-choice sound crazy when people
say things like, well, we actually never know.
Like, it's impossible to know and it's also
impossible to know, like when people die.
Like, I mean, it just makes things feel relative
and and I kind of.
I get lost in that.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
Yeah.
I mean, I think there's some value to, to
the speed limit analogy, which is like, listen,
sometimes.
To live in a society, we have to draw lines
where there are gray areas.
So you probably would have imagine a road
where you go, listen, 100 miles an hour, no
one's going to say 100 miles an hour is a
reasonable speed limit here and no one's going
to say that it's five.
We're going to set the speed limit at 40.
And certainly if it's dry and clear, you could
probably safely go 55.
If it's dark and icy, you're going to have
to go slower.
But this is where we're kind of drawing the
line.
And when we get into these rare circumstances
of like partial birth abortions, as they're
sometimes called, late term abortions, everybody
has a term that's loaded that they want to
apply to it.
And then they say, well, it's it's we're talking
about a person at seven months and someone
goes, well, here's one way where it would
really be six and here's another way it from
the standpoint of policy, sometimes lines
have to be drawn when things are blurry.
But this is a different question than if we
got an answer to when life begins, then do
we resolve the debate?
The answer is obviously no.
Speaker 3: Yeah, 100%.
Well, thanks a ton for your time.
Speaker 1: And thank you for the call.
I appreciate it.
All right.
There's a manual from Florida.